قبل المونديال اذا سالنا اي مشجع عن
توقعاتي في حال قابل المنتخب المغربي
نظيره الفرنسي في كاس العالم كان حتما
سيرجح كافه الديوك للفوز بالقاء لكن اليوم
نحن في نصف النهائي وبعد ما اقصى الاسود
البرتغال وقبلها اسبانيا وهزمت بلجيكا
تدخل المباراه بحسابات مختلفه ولا ارادها
غير اراده الفارس تصريحات وليد الرجراجي
مدرب المغرب تحمل نبره ايجابيه منذ بدء
المونديال يتحدث عن تغيير عقليه لاعبين
وتعديل نظره مشاركتهم في البطوله
مباراه فرنسا والعين على المباراه
النهائيه اليوم الموعد المنتظر على ملعب
البيت قلوبنا مع المغرب ونقول اللاعبين
سمعنا في اللقب بسبب الكون اذهبوا ولا
تبخلوا بقطره ومهما كانت النتيجه نحن
فخورنا بكرا
[موسيقى]
على حساب الجمهور
على حساب الجمهور ديالنا يستاهل
جمهور المغربي
ان شاء الله باذن الله الله غلبنانيهم
الله يفرحنا ان شاء الله وعدنا احساس انهم
غير بحوا ان شاء الله وغادي نفرحوا ان شاء
الله غير ربحوا بعزيمه واسرار الدراري
غيتقاتلوا بحال دارو مع الماتش البرتغال
ان شاء الله واحد لزيرو ان شاء الله
رابحين وتايل لاكوب باذن الله
حنا فرنسا
[موسيقى]
تكتيكي وقدره على تطبيق العديد من الرسوم
التكتيكيه خلال المباراه
والرغبه الكبيره في تحقيق ما يمكن بعد ما
يمكن في هذا المونديال يجعل المتفائل ان
المنتخب المغربي اليوم سوف يكون مفاجاه
ساره نعم المباريات الماضيه كان استحقاق
وصول المنتخب المغربي
لكن اليوم سوف تكون همم تكون مفاجاه يعني
مستحقه لمنتخب المغربي للوصول النهائيه
لان المنتخب المغربي اثبت انه جدير
بالوصول اليه
ما هي نقاط الضعف
لكل من الفريقين التي قد يستفيد منها كل
منهما بالنسبه للمنتخب
الفرنسي اقوى خط هجوم تقريبا يعني يملك
اسلحه خطيره جدا
جريزمان
ديمبري عثمان ديمبلي يعني لاعبين خطرين
جدا على مستوى الهجوم
بامكانياتهم الفنيه بامكانهم اختراق اي
دفاع لكن على مستوى الدفاع هناك بعض
الثغرات خاصه لما يتقدم المنتخب الفرنسي
والمنتخب الفرنسي دائما الهجوم وهمم يعني
بينافس يعني هجومي يؤدي في هذا المونديال
المنتخب المغربي يعني المنتخب كتله واحده
منسجم يعني على الاطراف
الوسط وهنا كده لاعبين ارتكاز قادرين على
افتكاك اي كوره اي مساحه للتقدم او همم
للتصوير على المرمى لكن يعني المنتخب
المغربي وهو همم الاستفاده من الهجمات
المرتده شاهدنا امام همم
اسبانيا امام البرتغال الكثير من
الانفرادات التي اضاعها مهاجمون المنتخب
المغربي وهذا يمكن ان لا يتكرر كثيره امام
فرنسا
[موسيقى]